i'm like wait a second this is crazy
it's the stroller drama we didn't see
coming coco austin claps back at her
haters for judging her parenting style
after the 43 year old model shared this
family photo with her hubby ice t and
their six-year-old daughter chanel
shopping in the bahamas things quickly
took a turn in coco's instagram comments
with trolls mom shaming her writing she
looks like she's over being in a baby
stroller isn't she like six years old
she should be out of a stroller by now
but leave it to mama bear because coco
she defended her decision to push chanel
in the stroller in a series of tweets
the model writes oh lord really people
the world loves to criticize literally
everything i do adding that this
shouldn't be a trending topic right now
isn't there a war and mass shootings
going on as we speak and you'd rather
mess with my mothering heartbeat
i never knew i could witness an angel so
beautiful
but coco isn't new to criticism back in
2021 her hubby came to her defense after
critics slammed her for breastfeeding a
then five-year-old chanel
the conditions create a necessity to say
something the 64 year old rapper tweeted
news flash we feed chanel food she just
likes to suck mom's boobs every now and
then me too all that stuff just makes me
laugh over the years coco has been
candid about her nursing journey
documenting her in chanel's bonding time
despite the backlash coco has built a
community of supportive mamas cheering
her on in 2020 she posted this pic and
wrote in the caption suck up as much
love as you can at this point in nursing
it's just for comfort and believe me the
girl loves meat so it's not like she
isn't eating real food one thing's for
sure this couple loves parenting their
little girl in 2018 they opened up to et
about spending quality time with chanel
and how parenthood has changed them
she's so much fun i mean i and like this
are my real life doll i get to dress her
up and we get to match all day it's
funny i didn't even think i was going to
be like that parent but i turned into
one she's a real fun it's like the best
best thing that happened to us keeps you
young doesn't it yes
i'm loving all of like the you know
stuff that i didn't like before
[Music]
you